well my instant feeling was to be
sickened by it want to show you one more
from Piers Morgan because Jordan
Peterson was on uh this is during the
ark conference just uh last week uh and
Piers asked Jordan about the growing
tide of
anti-Semitism where were you when you
first heard about it and what was your
instant feeling about
it well my instant feeling was to be
sickened by it I'm also more sensitive
to any signs of anti-semitic catastrophe
from
studying the Holocaust for the length of
time that I did and I've always regarded
Jews as the canary in the coal mine and
I think the reason that the Jews are the
Canary in the coal mine is because
they're a successful minority you know
and if a if a culture can tolerate a
successful minority it's pretty damn
robust and it's not very resentful and
as soon as a culture starts to get
resentful the Jews make an easy target
because they're a minority and so that's
an easy target to begin with but then
they the minority that has the tarity to
be successful that really brings the
resentful out of the Rat holes they're a
minority that has the temerity to be
successful that that is what the uh the
American dream is all about again this
is not about Jews you watching this
right now you're most likely a minority
in one way or another in even if you're
are white right like you C your
ancestors came here it's not I don't
mean minority in like the most narrow
view of it but everyone watching this
your ancestors basically came here with
nothing and then they probably worked a
lot harder than you have to work right
now just really think in your own mind
for yourself try to think about uh your
parents and your grandparents and your
great-grandparents however many
generations ago your people got here and
no one gave anyone anything certain
minorities were able to figure out how
to succeed within that system be it
through uh culture or tradition or
religion or belief or or any of those
things and that's what the American
dream is all about so when they go after
the Jews now the canary and the coal
mine line that Jordan's using is correct
it's just it's not going to end with
them they're the ones going guys there's
noxious poison in this coal mine and if
the canary drops dead a whole bunch of
us are going to drop dead all along uh
all alongside that Canary so everyone
has to care about this and we have to
figure out what will be those limits
that Douglas is talking about about Li
with liberal societies will liberal
societies die on The Sword of free
speech for everybody to the point of you
can call for the death of your
co-citizens
for you know for hundreds of years is
that the liberalism of the
Enlightenment I don't know maybe it is
if societies won't do anything in the
face of all this stuff